[Musique]
la martinique au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco on en parle on en parle même
depuis plusieurs années et pire il ya
une bataille qui fait rage pour savoir
qui en a eu l'idée en premier bonjour
nous traitent bonjour vous êtes le
président du parc naturel régional de
martinique la structure qui porte ce
dossier de cette inscription des volcans
forêts de la montagne pelée et des
pythons du nord de notre martinique à
l'unesco première question le goût
traîne pourquoi des pitons du nord en
son temps les pitons du carbet
normalement il ya des pitons du carbet
et le pit en dumont conil le piton
marcel qui sont des massifs volcaniques
du côté de la montagne pelée qui ont une
biodiversité exceptionnelle donc nous
avions dans notre dossier à la fois les
pitons du carbet mais l'ensemble des
pitons du nord puisque le pit ont gelé
par exemple sur la commune du monde
rouge n'appartient pas à la chaîne des
pitons du carbet
alors on en est où dans ce processus
d'inscription et des secours alors nous
avons trois étapes essentielles au
niveau national français est une étape
internationale devant un jury
international
nous avons validé en avril 2016 la
valeur universelle exceptionnelle du
bien sexe et la ligue arabe
c'est incroyable ministre de
l'environnement d'époque c'était c'est
une étape décisive dans le processus de
notre candidature description l'unesco
deuxième étape en 2017 qui était la
validation du périmètre du bien et là
nous avons quelques recommandations de
hal à froid du comité français au
patrimoine mondiale et de l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature
nous devons maintenant présenter la
dernière étape en octobre 2018 pour
pouvoir valider le plan de gestion parce
qu'il ne suffit pas d'avoir un bien et
sectionnelles extraordinaire qui a une
valeur universelle
mais il faut démontrer notre capacité au
nom des générations futures ou non de
l'humanité à préserver donc à gérer
convenablement ce bien le lot il
voterait pour être plus clair il faut
séduire la partie française qu'il ira
défendre ce dossier auprès de l'unesco
où nous en sommes dans cette phase
toujours non il y a la phase qui était
essentiel en
1016 citait le dossier scientifique
dossier de 800 pages que nous devons
devons démontrer la qualité de notre
bien sur deux critères essentiels à
savoir la biodiversité est un critère
sous lequel on ne nous attendait pas
mais nous avons insisté
nous avons sollicité l'appui du
professeur chossy donc et le directeur
de l'institut physique du globe de paris
et le professeur boudon qui indices type
d'haroun tazieff volcanologues pour
pouvoir démontrer que au nom du
volcanisme et de la géologie nous
pouvions être obtenue donc nous sommes
retenus sur deux critères le qui tire
biodiversité le cutter géologie
volcanisme la france jusqu'au mans jose
comment notre dossier au moment où on
parle pour l'instant le parc naturel de
martinique porte le dossier pour le
compte de la ctm et de liszt à l'état
nous accompagne puisque nous avons suivi
au niveau du ministère de la transition
écologique c'était le ministère de
l'écologie et nous qui nous accompagnent
justement dans la préparation de ce
dossier
alors dans ce dossier il faut savoir
démontrer qu'on pourra préserver le site
qu'on saura valoriser le site et que
tout le monde est unanime pour que
autres en martinique pour que ce dossier
aboutisse ceux sur les bureaux de
l'unesco
on sait y faire on sait faire à côté du
plan de gestion
il y à ce qu'on appelle un dossier de
mobilisation notre capacité aujourd'hui
à démontrer que l'ensemble de la
population
les organismes civile les institutions
suivent et porter le projet il est
essentiel pour la martinique d'avoir une
autre image à l'international les
mairies vous suivre les municipalités
nous n'avons pas l'obligation dans le
dossier de candidature d'abord des
délibérations mais personnellement à
pourquoi vous parlez des délibérations
non je vous explique pourquoi
c'est un acte fondateur de droit et
l'immigration et il est important
d'avoir cet acte là dans le dossier même
si ce n'est pas une obligation
nous avons 18 communes d'une communauté
d'agglo la cacem et quatre non n'oubliez
pas que les massifs que 2 du ii du moz
et puis ton du musée et le pitchoun
d'alma sont sur le territoire de fort de
france
lorsque quelqu'un que vous connaissez
bien l'ancien président du parc naturel
régional daniel chomet estime effet
savoir qui veut l'entendre que dans ce
dossier vous prenez pas très bien sur
cette question justement de l'adhésion
des municipalités sk8 polémiquer sur sa
non je dis que aujourd'hui l'image que
nous envoyons à l'extérieur c'est une
image de pollution du cema la martinique
c'est une terre de pollution pour lui
chant chlordécone pollution eau sans gaz
polluants atmosphériques avec la bundes
à blé les particules fines donc
n'ajoutons pas de la pollution des
intellectuels à nos débats essayant
justement de faire peuple autour d'un
projet fédérateur c'est un projet de
territoire qui attendu par les
populations puisque il y a 30 à 40 %
d'augmentation de la fréquentation pour
les sites classés une et salons
saisissons donc attendez là d'abord je
suis pas autre chose savaient que en
martinique nous avons une commune qui
s'appelle saint pierre qui était classée
ville d'art et d'histoire et vous savez
également que autour de cette
appellation ville d'art et d'histoire
mais on estimait que à quoi ça sert vert
n'a pas su valoriser
est-ce qui est ce qu'apple risque de
voir beaucoup plus grand avec cette
inscription niveau 2 millisecondes et
qu'on ne sache pas attirer tous les
profits de cette situation il y a seat
saint pierre il ya certes le mont rouge
mais à 18 communes qui sont intéressés
par cette démarche est la question c'est
est ce qu'on saura vraiment utilisé à
100% cette appellation patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
ce n'est pas l'utilisation d'un label
simplement
certes ça nous donne ça nous rend ces
prestigieux d'avoir cette lisibilité
internationale sur le plan de la tête
l'attractivité du territoire
mais je le répète c'est vraiment un
projet de territoire de développement
avec un projet de gestion comme les
vaincre d'auvergnats comme niveau qu'on
devienne c'est d'ailleurs le seul volcan
le seul site naturel français qu'ils
soient classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
les trois autres c'est effectivement à
la réunion on à la barrière de corail à
nouvelle calédonie et il y a également
en corse un site classé au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco alors louis boutrin
les
échéance là vous avez parlé de d'octobre
tout de suite après cette inscription au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco pour que
ce soit effectif
la 'deadline' minimum ce serait quoi
nous devons déposer le dossier définitif
après la le loup de l'audition que nous
avons en octobre 2018 nous devons
déposer le dossier définitif en février
ensuite il appartiendra à la l'ultime
étape à l'état français puisque nous
sommes dans le cadre des nations unies
l'unesco l'organisation des nations
unies pour la paix pour la préservation
de la science de la culture
donc cette organisation doit recevoir la
candidature des états membres donc
recevoir le dossier de candidature de la
france c'est la france qui porte le
dossier d'accord alors lui coûterait il
nous reste quelques secondes
dites moi que tout cela ça va aboutir
forcément à la création d'emplois
tourisme
peut-être des guides conférenciers
ce serait une filière pour la martinique
c'est une filière et nous allons un peu
plus loin puisque vous avez bien compris
que nous organisons aujourd'hui
séminaire international avec les autres
états de la caraïbe jamaïque sainte
lucie et dominique qui sont déjà
labellisés
cuba n'a pas pu venir plus cuba est
labellisé de manière avant un échange
d'expériences sur le plan scientifique
la martinique doit devenir une terre de
congrès notamment de congrès
scientifiques en partenariat avec
l'université des antilles
c'est ça notre objectif parce que là
aussi il y à toute une série de filières
que nous scientifiques que nous allons
mettre en place y compris un certain
nombre d'emplois dans le domaine vous le
disiez du tourisme de la restauration
des jt tout et des guides de manière à
ce qu'on puisse valoriser notre
territoire
voilà un projet fédérateur empoché
sculpture un beau lamartine que le
projet fédérateur et si par hasard ça ne
fonctionne pas si par hasard ça ne
fonctionne pas on en tirera quelque
chose quand même
on en tire à quelque chose mais restons
pessimistes vous savez quand il ya une
personne qui rêve ce n'est qu'un rêve
mais quand nous sommes plusieurs à
partager ce rêve
c'est déjà une réalité merci louis
boutrin d'avoir été avec nous rappelle
que vous êtes président du parc naturel
régional de martinique concernant cette
inscription de la montagne pelée des
pitons du nord à lunel merci de m'avoir
reçu
[Musique]